ان شاء الله القشطر يفوز يا فاطمه ولكن
بدي من اليوم ستكون المواجهات الكرويه
حاميه الوطيس من يخسر سيغادر مونديال
القطري للاسف ومن يربح مباراهه سيشق
الطريق النهائي للفوز بكاس العالم 2022
هناك في الدوحه يعني ستقام اليوم مباراه
المنتخب الهولندي ضد المنتخب الامريكي
الساعه السادسه يعني بعد ثلاث ساعات من
الان بتوقيت طبعا السعوديه وقطر في ملعب
خليفه الدولي ومباراه الارجنتين ضد
استراليا سعد 10 بس ليلا بتوقيت السعوديه
وقطر في ملعب احمد بن علي يعني اثار قناه
الارجنتيه فاطمه الشكوك حول وجود شبه
تواطئ في مباراه منتخب بلادها امام بولندا
ضمن منافسات الجوله الاخيره للمجموعه
الثالثه في نهائيات كاس العالم 2022 وتاهل
طبعا منتخب الارجنتين متصدرا لمجموعته عقد
فوزه على بولندا بهدفين دون مقابل ومنح
همم فارق الاهداف البطاقه الثانيه لبولندا
على حساب المكسيك التي حلت ثالثا برصيد
اربع نقاط لكن يعني لكل منهما همم اخذ
اربع نقاط ونشرت قناه تي واي سي
الارجنتينيه تقريرا قالت من خلاله بعد
تاخر بولندا بهدفين دون مقابل بدات التوتر
يتصاعد بين البولنديين بسبب وضعيتها في
التاهل همم حينها اتجه طبعا ليونيل ميسي
الى مكان وجود البدلاء ووجهها سؤانا
التقته التقطته الكاميرات ورد عليه المدرب
اليونيس كالوني الذي هضم من مقاعد البدلاء
ليقترب منه واضاف يعني هذا التقرير
التليفزيون التقدير لافته على فكره من
الواضح ان النجم الارجنتين كان يهتم
بنتيجه مباراه السعوديه والمكسيك وكان
حينها المكسيك متقدم بهدف بهدفين دون
مقابل